what up guys welcome to the just early
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to a finishing school
from the 1970s before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification Bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way in and
subscribe to the channel as you guys
already know we have a hefty probably
impossible I'm gonna be honest probably
impossible goal of hitting a million
before New Year's but you never know so
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell play the video
blessing yeah this is such an
enthusiastic
and remember when you're doing your turn
to make a smooth and graceful right
would you like to come down and do a
half turn for me please
these women are buying sixty dollars
worth of professional Gardens in
Department grooming social and business
oh my God I need help with that I'm so
awkward I would not know how to do like
a a turn like that somebody somebody
have that lady message me we're gonna
bring her on to wife school and
conversation techniques they've come to
the pat Woodley Beauty School in answer
to this message many astute wives have
realized that their husband's future
success can only be achieved if they
groom themselves for new social strata
the school reinforces its ability to
turn out better executive wives with a
seductive series of before and after
photographs
look at and the girls that today will be
like I won't change for no man these
women were like I'm holding my husband
back I'm not doing enough okay
[Music]
and this beauty school is not just
cashing in on the desire of every woman
to be more attractive it's a fact that
many Australian companies today insist
on checking out the wife of a
prospective executive Brian Chan is
managing director of a firm which finds
I want to do that put the book on my
head I've been told I have bad posture
in the videos so I actually wanted to do
a a series in wife school about posture
which you should go check out Link in
the description
um but put a book on my head I should
try that one day
why are you laughing blessing I'm trying
I'm trying to be the best version of me
I can be yeah thank you pop men to feel
highly paid executive jobs and top women
to go with them it's not normal practice
to interview the wife but there are
other ways of finding out about her the
client when he gets to what we call the
short list and he's looking at say three
finalists will say well I think the time
is right for us to have a look at uh Mrs
finalist and this may be done by virtue
of a dinner party where the managing
director of the client company and his
wife may go out with the finalist and
his wife and I have known of this
resulting in rejection of the applicant
because of the fact that the wife didn't
measure up how else do you find damn
damn can you imagine oh you fumbled a
man's job oh my God what you want to
know about an executive's wife
presumably there are personal references
are there oh yes each referee will
supply us with references uh sometimes
one really between the lines on these
references and in the course of our
discussions with him we might sort of
casually ask what sort of neighbors he
has and we equally casually ask what the
neighbor's name happens to be and then
using the most convenient means we have
of the telephone we find that we're
talking to the neighbor concerning uh Mr
applicant and or his wife's attitudes
the way they get on home and things like
this so there are various ways of making
it they would be sued doing that today
oh my God they would be sued we live in
America this is the land of lawsuits oh
my God you would get your ass sued very
Frank an honest approach to a person
once I would say he has reached really
senior level we're from fifteen thousand
dollars upwards then I would say that
they want to know what she's like at
entertaining is she able to mix with
people has she made the letter as well
as her husband had kept up with him in
All respects and easy to mix with then
they would really want to know going
delve into these facts about her miss
Robin bra is office manager for another
Management Consultant who recruits
Executives for its client companies girl
why aren't you crossing your leg you see
you notice that I'm like girl
all right and is that the personal
referee level that you would inquire
about what the wife is like because this
is people who know them who've mixed
with them socially they can give an
indication how she mixes drinks smokes
and generally conducts herself and
therefore you would gauge this
information that way does the company
want to go any further than that ever
for example a moral reputation this sort
of obviously this goes without saying I
feel also a company in many cases they
don't want other Executives to know that
they are recruiting a particular man for
the job they might meet him off limits
and this way the chief executive would
also make the wife off limits for on the
other hand he's secretary might
entertain the wife for luncheon she can
see what she's like her dress sense at
all both day and night level and this
way they can assess what she is like and
is she keeping up with her husband have
you on behalf of your company ever been
in the position of professionally
observing the wife of a prospective
employee yes I have I have been called
upon by coincidence so happen that I
knew these people and they're also
client fly was required to ended in the
party and I as a matter of fact to give
you an example only last week I was at a
function where a young executive wife
was there it was a dinner party long
dress was worn of course and she had a
style on her first stove it was a stall
I first start I don't know what that I'm
guessing it's like a short skirt that's
that's what I feel like and how critical
the eye is the matron when she was
leaving called her over and said I don't
know whether you realize dear that the
tails on first old have gone out she
took them off and said put these in your
handbag and perhaps you'd like to have a
fur collar made she was being critical
of the fact that she hadn't kept up with
fashion and that they were spawning her
outfit oh wow
wow oh my gosh that is so Cutthroat dude
I I am the most fashionable I don't know
if I would pass
I don't know if I would pass I would go
to the school though that's so
interesting but do you seriously make
the point that a small point a small
point of fashion perhaps like that could
influence whether or not a man's going
to be chosen for a job no but I think
that that's one is one point but then
perhaps there could be other points
where she hasn't kept up her ability to
mix with people her knowledge of world
affairs if she slipped up in one thing
then perhaps she slipped up on others
okay I will say that's kind of true
because I've been so my parents um they
sold their business a couple years ago
and they they got into what they call
like private banking and you do go to
these like super nice events and yeah
it's really interesting to see the types
of people at these events because
sometimes like I think I was too
impressed I won't lie I went to this so
I was like um it was in downtown Chicago
and the event was at the um you call it
it's at this Museum in downtown Chicago
it's like this big Museum and they rent
it out and they have a speaker they
there and that time it was the Prime
Minister from Britain and I can't
remember his name he was like the prime
minister of blessing for like 10 years
here in like the 90s you know I don't I
don't know some some big prime minister
I can't even remember but um and then he
gives a speech and then everyone like
talks after and I was so impressed I
walk in there and I'm like wow free food
and I'm like wow
oh my gosh this is so
this is so I'm in my lawn dress and I
won't lie um I don't think the people
there were impressed by me I don't know
if I would pass like like because the
lady's there you could just tell they
were like used to this type of Lifestyle
but and they were all like ah talking
about all the that I was like I
don't even care and I was just running
around trying all the snacks my mom was
embarrassed to me
sorry Mom
she wasn't yeah well but it taught me
something and it it taught me actually
two things one doesn't have anything to
do with this topic one is that even
though they all had a stupid amount of
money I was the richest one in there
because I had Youth and none of y'all
can buy Youth and that's the one thing
it's like you could have all the money
in the world but who who's richer the
guy that's 90 and has billions or the
guy that's 22 Yeah so um that was my
thought that doesn't really have
anything to do with this video too was
that in these upper echelons Excellence
Escalon
of society
um they really are fancy like I grew up
in a different I don't know how to put
in it's like a different class like I
grew up with the rich people that didn't
really like to spend money and weren't
really involved in these like Elite
circles like we kind of just my dad
bought a piece of land and we all hung
out on it we will never fly we will
always drive because I'm gonna save my
money I don't care how much money I eat
like that's the kind of circle drop it
but there's these other circles that are
just like Elite almost and it's like
they're they always have like the most
fancy clothes they're always at like the
most popping events and they all know
about current events and all that stuff
yeah I don't think I would pass yeah
sorry
the point of view did you feel uh in any
way a bit like big brother and having to
make this observation that you were
intruding inside why didn't I felt was
part of my job do you think that wives
on an occasion like you describe are
quite aware that they're under
surveillance and the reason for this I
think if they're not then they're an
unwise why this girl is sharp I like her
like I'm not saying I would pass this
test but I respect the game like that
girl she's sharp if she's not she's an
unwise wife damn there's an applicant
for a job ever express surprise or maybe
even just Taste of the idea of his wife
being appraised as well as himself no I
don't think so I think if he's at that
level that he should have I can think of
a case of an executive who's rise to
Fame in his organization uh stopped
Philly suddenly because of the fact that
he had when he got married at a fairly
young age married a less somewhat um I
don't want to be snobbish in saying this
but below his station in life so that as
he progressed at the rate that one could
expect his wife didn't uh she was
somewhat illiterate and and this became
a real restricting factor for this
fellow's growth I thought he was going
to say she got fat
well what can you do about it he has a
couple of choices open to him it is
possible that his wife if she is
genuinely interested in the progression
of her husband in his vocation we'll do
something about improving herself or her
English and there are many ways open for
her to do this or if it's the question
of her uh her dress or her presentation
of herself she can do something about
this on the other hand it's quite
possible that the executive will decide
that he's not going to be frustrated in
the entertainment of his goals and
therefore he does something a little bit
more drastic he decides to you know get
a new wife my husband
damn oh that's just ruthless oh my gosh
I bet they would be appalled if they saw
the women today they would be appalled
because it's not even oh that she's not
smart enough like it's that they're like
we don't even need a girl with a PhD
they're too educated we just want him to
lose weight they would be a pulp at the
I can't say that word anymore at the
beautiful majestic creatures of today
sounds extremely well groomed and
fashion conscious and if I lag behind
he's liable to tell me so so I'd like to
get you know better you hear that
submission you hear that grooming and
makeup and more confidence generally so
in a way you're doing this to keep up
with him yes in fact yes I'm hoping for
a miracle I think
we're hoping for a miracle what does
that mean well I need a lot of polishing
up and I'd like to be more sure of
myself I am very unsure myself
Dawn Burton is a graduate of Pat
Woodley's executive wife course she's
married to the marketing manager for one
of Australia's largest printing firms
and says more than half of his work is
done socially especially at home these
days Mrs Burton has the table set at 10
o'clock in the morning for tonight's
dinner party but there was a time when
she didn't manage so well and her
husband suggested she should do
something to become a better executive
wife yes as a matter of fact he had done
something himself about being a better
executive and he'd gone to a
phrenologist a phrenologist is a person
that puts his hands through your hair
fills your bumps and then sits back and
enjoys conversation with you and then
helps you adjust your way of thinking so
your husband suggested that you should
so he suggested maybe I'd like to do
this because other executive's wives had
more or less had an inspection from this
person to see whether they were able to
cope with Advanced positions that their
husband may have these girls are kind of
hot red blast it like I didn't see one
girl in here not one like I bet how old
do you think she is like 30 smash or
pass yeah easy smash like we used to
look so much better objectives she looks
better than a lot of girls in their 20s
nowadays you're acquaintance little
friends I have known of a person who did
and her husband never ever went any
further in that camp because they felt
it it was better he didn't she just
wasn't able to cope and I think had she
gone maybe she would have been more in
my position where she would accept this
and and realize that it was all for both
their advantages so you've changed as it
were into almost the ideal executive's
wife I hope so but uh this has become an
increasing Trend a trend setting oh she
hoped incorrectly hope does nothing yeah
it got worse oh show this to women today
oh my God show this to women today and I
think that it's a good Factor coming
into our business we're trying to be
smart in all respects we just don't have
a smart secretary we have a smart wife
as well
is a company face it smiles and
Executives then goes back in place the
company Furniture oh it suits me fine
the company letterhead a valentine so
you play it the company way all company
policy is by me okay you'll never I want
to do the book thing rise up to the top
as one thing clear whoever the company
fires I will still be you will still be
here after fiscal never pick a risk
all right comment below if I should do
the book challenge is that all I gotta
do to work on my posture I just got to
put a book on my head should I do that
for a show
okay guys like the video I'm on your way
out this is so cool where'd you find
this blessing Secrets I don't know this
was so interesting to watch I would
totally go to that do you think they
still got those yeah well um if you guys
know any in London
um or even in the US but you'd have to
work quick with the us because we're
going there pretty soon
um but let me know like the video um on
your way out subscribe to the channel
ring that notification Bell and I'll
talk to you next time